une des grandes avancées en sciences
biologiques ces dernières années a été
la découverte du système plus +15 9 1
ciseaux moléculaires de ce thème crespo
15v de bactéries donc c'est un phénomène
curiosité de la microbiologie crise peut
15,9 est un système naturel qui se
trouve au sein de nombreuses bactéries
ce système leur permet de se défendre
contre les virus qui les attaquent
c'est en fait à ciseaux moléculaires qui
coupe un segment d'adr du virus
envahisseurs le tuant sur le coup
[Musique]
la découverte de cette capacité de
couper l'adn laisse entrevoir la
possibilité de modifier le génome de
tout être vivant et annonce une
véritable révolution en microbiologie
des fois ça nous arrive de se pincer
parce qu'on sait qu'on va se réveiller
un beau rêve
le microbiologiste sylvain moineau de
l'université laval à québec et l'un des
scientifiques
on joue un rôle fondamental dans la
compréhension de crue sparkasse 9 en
découvrant entre autres l'endroit précis
où ce système couper l'adn on étudiait
des bactéries qu'on utilise pour
fabriquer du haut cours pour fabriquer
du fromage
on voulait comprendre pourquoi certains
de ces bactéries l'eau sont résistantes
à des virus résistants tu as des farges
on a étudié le mécanisme qui était
responsable de ce qui naturellement
présent ces bactéries l'eau de ce thème
crise pour 15 ans de démontrer que ça
couper l'adn ya des gens qui ont fait un
outil extraordinaire donc de penser
qu'on étudiait le fromage le yogi
hôpitaux aujourd'hui on serait peut-être
rendu à traiter certaines maladies
génétiques
c'est incroyable
c'est à partir de la découverte de cette
capacité naturelle de prusse brocas 9 de
couper l'adn que les scientifiques ont
pu faire un outil de recherche
extrêmement puissant on peut programmer
cet outil là pour aller couper dans un
endroit précis du génome que ce soit
d'une cellule humaine grâce à une plante
ou d'une bactérie
une fois que le génome est coupée à
celle doit se réparer parce que sinon
elle va mourir et à partir de ce moment
là on peut lui disais la cellule quand
tu vas te réparer je veux qu'elle soit
réparé de la façon dont moi je donc on
peut être dur une mutation peut corriger
une mutation on peut même introduire un
nouveau gène c'est un outil qui nous
permet de faire des avancées incroyants
pour la compréhension d'une panoplie de
cellules et d'organismes l'un des
espoirs que suscite crispe le cast 9 et
pouvoir guérir des maladies héréditaires
en permettant de corriger le gène
défectueux à l'origine de la pathologie
et sur les maladies génétiques qui sont
ciblés présentement parce que l'idée
c'est qu'on n'a pas besoin de tout mode
fini 6e
on peut en modifier une traction et ça
pourrait avoir un impact positif chez
les gens l'hémophilie par exemple ces
maladies génétiques
on n'a pas besoin d'avoir toutes les
cellules dont jeanne été corrigé
sylvain moineau souligne que la
technique de crise perd 4,9
quoique précise ne l'est pas à 100% des
erreurs peuvent se produire si les
recherches sur les maladies génétiques
sont porteuses d'espoir elles doivent
toutefois procéder prudemment et des
essais cliniques sont en cours mais on
essaie vraiment voir si l'outil vont
être assez précis dans un contexte de
thérapies humaines
quant aux expériences sur les cellules
reproductrices humaine elles sont
interdits au canada et à moratoire
international a été réclamée par des
scientifiques afin d' empêcher des
dérives comme celle qui s'est produite
en chine où des jumelles génétiquement
modifiés par chris paul cash neuf sont
nés en 2018
si un élément positif des travaux
comptait fin en chaîne à retenir c'est
que la réponse internationale
les gens ont décrié ce qui s'est passé
donc est vraiment une conscientisation
l'apport des scientifiques l'apport du
public
donc j'ai assez confiance que les gens
vont respecter le moratoire
[Musique]